[Musique]
à 36 ans et ancien charpentier de marine
commence à percer dans le monde du
spectacle sous le nom de johnny rock
sosie de l'autre johnny qu'on est bien
dans la peau d'une aile d'être assez
formidable bien sûr johnny n'est pas
celui que vous croyez
d'ailleurs son fils ne s'appelle pas
david mais maximilien et son vrai nom à
lui c'est c'est renoncer
jacquot henry bonsoir mon nom de scène
c'est johnny star s'est rendue aux
petits poissons des rapprochements
france
cette légende vivante c'est un mythe et
pour moi c'est mon dieu contrairement
aux sept autres clones de la star du
rock
il a décidé de ne pas en faire son
métier mais quand on vous reconnaît sa
me fais quoi moi c'est marrant des fois
c'est un peu irritant mais c'est marrant
moi je trouve ça beau et qu'est ce
qu'elle a ma gueule
le plus dur c'est d'arriver à faire les
yeux de johnny parce que bon j'ai pas
quand même tout à fait le même regard
bonjour c'est johnny bienvenue dans
l'univers de géniale idée que je
collectionne depuis 1979
c'est ma vie ni ses 70 amour qu'on peut
rencontrer je pense moi fédéraux
d'étonner les gens ils sont
impressionnés quand même quand ils
voyaient tu arrives en voiture en 4 4 2
avec les carreaux tout ça fume et qui
c'est qui va descendre tout ça est aussi
total à musique qui parle et moi
j'arrive sur scène je commence comme
johnny une l'âge improvisé richie achève
la métamorphose
devant son miroir le taulier appareils
de johnny que la michael cette année
[Musique]